it's just harder to get 10 million views
on a video helping people than it is to
get 10 million views on a video tearing
down a celebrity you know what I mean or
whatever negative video you want to
insert there well that said most of your
videos are pretty positive so what's but
not a lot of people do those kinds of
videos because they're hard yeah they're
hard yeah uh some of that is giving away
money right yeah
um what's the secret to that what's how
do you do do that right yeah like give
away money or in a video that may to
make it compelling
um is it so there's a number that is
better than another number right the
higher number is always better than the
other number yeah for the most part and
you know it's interesting like some
videos will give away a million dollars
some videos will give away half a
million there's not really I guess so
I'm retracting what I just said I was
more joking with that but there's no
difference whether I put 500k or a
million it's probably not even really a
difference between 100K a million I
haven't really looked into it like some
of our mostly videos are not us giving
away a million dollars and sometimes the
million dollar videos just don't do as
well as the other ones so there there's
a certain point where a dollar amount is
just a large dollar amount to an average
human and so I think that point is 100k
like anything above 100K the average
human's just like that's a lot of money
you know it doesn't it doesn't 100K a
million like it doesn't really move the
needle if that makes sense which that's
a very nuanced piece of information that
applies to very few people but yeah well
no I think it applies it's fascinating
it's fascinating human our relationship
with money is fascinating like why is it
so exciting to get
I mean I you know the times I found like
20 bucks in the ground
are like incredible really I don't know
why right why why are you so happy like
what exactly is so joyful about that I
mean it depends where you are in life
what the situation is yeah I don't know
there's also a gamified aspect to it
it's exciting yes no I get it like why
people want to see people win money it's
just interesting that past 100 Grand
it's it doesn't really seem to make a
difference like it's the same basically
so you found that to be true with all
the money you've given away that I just
didn't click through it like obviously
in terms of someone receiving it yeah a
million dollars changes their life
drastically more
like that's the difference like oh you
if you wanted to you could really quit
your job as opposed to 100K is like not
really you probably do like a scientific
study like a formula giving away money
to click-through rate yeah there could
be some kind of digestion return it
definitely the the returns level off
dramatically after 100K that's basically
the premise what about ten thousand uh
no there's ten a hundred thousand is
that this is funny because this is such
a small Niche thing but yeah a hundred
thousand does it from what I see in our
videos get more clicks than ten thousand
but the difference between 100 000
million is just so little I just I think
big number big number to a lot of people
past that point yeah so for a hundred
thousand you can like give an average
salary you could probably live for a
year given given a day out average
salaries in America so that's like a big
that feels yeah I think it's also just
more when they read the title it's just
like it's a lot of zeros [ __ ] loads of
zeros Okay click yeah
foreign